alors on va faire l'interview nul
il a bougé dans tout le monde était
parfait et 3 qu'eric est exemplaire avec
moi je suis obligé de donner l'exemple
exemplaires est ce que vous préférez
votre père ou votre mère proches
préfèrent les deux j'ai pas de choix
c'est dur à ça non j'ai dit que c'était
des questions bon ça oui mais il n'y a
pas de choix
elle sut c'est une question qu'on mais
j'en étais sûr qu est ce que vous
préférez hitler ou staline dit pas les
deux alors c'est le coup de duclos la
peste ou le choléra
ah ouais je peux pas choisir non plus
c'est important on vous les mettez au
même niveau je déteste les deux voies là
non parce que c'est qu'en france ya
toujours des gens qui vous explique que
staline c'est mieux qu hitler
je ne partais pas de ce principe là
n'ont bien sûr pas mal
vous devez partir sur une île déserte
c'est un jeu de l'esprit un vous préféré
partir avec des tapis ou dominique
strauss kahn
alors il n'y a pas de y'a pas toi y'a
pas photo dominique strauss kahn pour
les cassettes est un ami ouais et
j'assume cette amitié complètement ça
c'est un bon côté vous avez les
socialistes bout c'est à dire que les
mecs peuvent faire les pires trucs vous
les soutenez toujours c'est voter me
taire mon ami non son ami et je suivais
pas à juger tel ou tel chose c'est mon
ami donc parti avec dominique strauss
kahn c'est jospin est mon ami c'est mon
ami d'accord voilà oui bien sûr il est
sympa il veut nous dire plus à tirer
après se seraient ils ont du mal là pour
avoir l'air sympa là il a fait douze
pages dans gala j'aime bien quand vous
regardez comme ça
là j'ai la charge je sais pas si tu as
le regarde de claude hallais quand tu me
regardes etc les yeux plissés comme ça
quand tu lui dis une question qu'il en
meure dit il que la hotte question qu'on
vous laver les cheveux tous les combien
tous les jours à mon précédent avons
bien ce qu'il veut
est ce que vous préférez un président de
la république d'extrême droite élu au
suffrage universel ou pas d'élection du
tout pas d'élection du tout vous arrêtez
d'être démocratique à un moment quand ça
vous arrange plus vous arrêter d'être
démocrate ou me posais une question pour
être d'accord
ça me rappelle en algérie quand même et
joue pour le cas si ça va y gagner les
élections en algérie on arrêter le
processus
vous me posez une question je vous
réponds qu'à programme rds me dire
qu'est bataille qui est fontaine je
connaissais bataille et fontaine
je connais un joueur de foot qui
s'appelle fonta juste fontaine bien sûr
que ces rentes 58 la suède alors vous
connaissez pas bataille et fontaine
pourrais pas me dire qu'est bataille et
fontaine
non sarah s coupé me dire qu'ils aient
bataille qui est fontaine
ce sont des comiques non non ce sont des
présentations sur comics ou d'une
certaine façon mais une campagne sans
présentateur sur tf1 y'a pas photo qui
est bataille qui est fontaine y en a un
qui est grand marien qui est un peu plus
petit un peu plus gros lequel les
batailles lequel les fontaines alors je
crois que pascal 5,30 pascal qu'est
bataille mais c'est pas de m'embrouiller
et fontaine
quand nc le nom mais là j'ai linda
cardiaque non mais ça c'est une question
interne de deux pas du tout part de
marché tous les lundis soir catherine me
dit que vous avez raison vous savez que
les batailles qui est fontaine alors
tout d'abord est ce que vous aimeriez
avoir un nez supplémentaire ni
suppléments des supplémentaires analyse
supplémentaire un doigt supplémentaire
ou un sexe supplémentaires j'aimerais
avoir un oeil supplémentaires ah bon
derrière à droite a peur de te remettre
loyauté filtre en même temps est-ce
qu'on préférait une femme n'aime pas
tellement faire l'amour mais qui est
fidèle ou une femme qui adore faire
l'amour mais était un fidèle babala
deuxième bien sûr ah oui ça c'est bien
les nouvelles atteste je pense pas que
l'attesterait sur allègre mais allait
bien c'était à l'exception de questions
c'est vraiment une bonne idée donc vous
préférez une femme qui aime faire
l'amour et au risque qu'elle soit
infidèle
oui au risque au risque ouais et vous
vous préférez un garçon qui s'est tenue
à 2 parce que vous pouvez espérer si
vous avez sur la combler qu'elle soit là
par kaleme ferns agathois la merci de
l'explication et vous vous préférez un
garçon qui sait pas très bien faire
l'amour mais qui est très fidèle ou un
garçon qui était merveilleusement
l'amour un italien un génial et tout
mais qui en même temps voilà il court
partout mais d'italiens sont souvent
infidèles donc vous en prenez votre
parti même choix choix et c'est que la
france entière se demande quel est votre
numéro de portable ça merci bon ici avec